people are hating but mark my words i
will still get
the job done yeah so it's just
babysitting the rookies while i take the
night out
man i love that i have to mentor you
time for bed oops i broke it look i'm
not
oh no now i'm down you can't smoke i'm a
month
older than you bro
[Music]
so the raven killed them all good night
see you in your nightmares
i'm used to no guards should i start
survive not two times it's not
bedtime pew pew everybody knows how to
continue
now you guys are dead with dispatcher
gets back from the concert
yo i'm looking slick thrown picks asking
vic will i stick am i the franchise guy
we don't know oh no he's running
children are not the future
i am the future wait who are you hi i'm
future trivia
answer jake luton the babies have been
set
uh i'm garrett gilbert and i've actually
been around since 2014.
[Music]
he wants you to subscribe but jimmy also
wants
a hug just because we be
team monster don't mean we be monster
monster i must eat to survive